go soir jean-claude beaujour merci à
danser avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors les pros avant vont démontrer que
donald trump a abandonné son rôle de
commandant en chef pour devenir lé
incitateur en chef d'une dangereuse
insurrection ce sont les mots du
procureur démocrate
de quelles preuves parle-t-il je pense
que à ce stade une chose qui est
certaine et nous avons vu dans looking
statement du camp du procureur démocrate
des représentants de la chambre des
représentants
nous avons vu la première vidéo la vidéo
de l'attak d'une part ça c'est c'est le
fait et deuxièmement qu'il faut
absolument lié ce sont les propos du
président et donc je pense qu'au cours
de ce procès ce corps affaire
l'accusation c'est de lier les propos
aux faits aux actes illicites y ont été
commis et de faire endosser à donald
trump une responsabilité directe ça sera
ça ne te travail des du procureur de
l'accusation de véritablement de rendre
donald trump directement responsables
des actes ont été commis
et puis en face on vous expliquera et je
pense que c'est ce que tentera de faire
la défense la défense tentera de dire le
président n'a jamais dit directement à
ses supporters d'aller marque de non
seulement d'aller au capitole mais en
plus d'avoir le comportement qu'il a eu
d'ailleurs vous dire à vous diront ses
avocats très rapidement et par la suite
je quelques jours après il a indiqué que
ce sont des comportements qui n'étaient
pas normaux qu'il demandait que c'est
être que l'amérique c'est un état de
droit etc etc on voit bien que ce qui
sera apprécié par les sénateurs c'est là
la ligne véritablement extrêmement ténue
sur laquelle s'est situé donald trump le
jour ce 6 janvier
alors on le sait que cette procédure de
destitution un peu de chances d'aboutir
dans le fond jean claude beaujour
qu'elle en est
l'enjeu un enjeu d'image aussi pour
donald trump alors pas seulement tout
d'abord il faut il faut malgré tout
attendre même s'il y a peu de chances
que le camp démocrate arrive à rallier
les 17 c'est les 17 sénateurs manquant
pour pouvoir faire une majorité de 60 %
il y à une deuxième chose c'est que si
évidemment fonction de l'évolution du
procès donald trump pourrait sortir son
image pourrait sortir extrêmement
écornée mais dans le même temps ça peut
raviver la division américaine et
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
le président baden ne souhaitait pas ce
procès la conséquence peut-être de
raviver le véritablement la polarisation
de la société américaine
la conséquence peut-être aussi de faire
exploser définitivement le parti
républicain
peut-être que certains nombre de
républicains souhaitent se débarrasser
définitivement de donald trump
mais dans le même temps n'oublions pas
que sur les 72 74 millions d'électeurs
qui ont voté pour donald trump
ce dernier a au moins une vingtaine de
millions de supporters extrêmement actif
et qui seront se faire entendre dans des
prochains scrutins
à commencer par le scrutin qu'il y aura
dans 2 1 qui verront un certain nombre
de candidats républicains probablement
en difficulté donc vous voyez l'enjeu
n'est pas simplement jury n'est pas
simplement judiciaire melliti 8 aussi
politiques et sociales pour la
démocratie américaine
alors justement david chane à l'un des
avocats de donald trump a estimé que ce
procès était je cite une
instrumentalisation politique de la
procédure de destitution qui allait le
site pour rejoindre vos mots d'ailleurs
déchiré le pays qui est déjà très
divisée
on le sait les américains finalement ne
sont pas dupes de cette
instrumentalisation
je pense tout d'abord que les américains
très rapidement penseront et pensent à
autre chose vous savez pour tous ceux
qui saoule à son compte la famille aux
états unis où séjourne aux états unis
la préoccupation des américains comme
elle est la préoccupation des français
aujourd'hui c'est deux à de retrouver un
emploi
et là le sujet est prégnant aux états
unis donc que ce sont ces le plan que va
mettre en place
joe biden au cours de ses 100 premiers
jours c'est le plan de quasiment 2 mille
milliards qui est sur la table qui est
en discussion parce que les gens ont
besoin d'un emploi les gens veulent
éviter d'être expulsés de leur logement
ils veulent pouvoir avoir accès pour
ceux qui sont malades c'est cela la
préoccupation des américains aujourd'hui
parce qu'il n'aura échappé à personne
que nous vivons tous une situation très
exceptionnelle avec le coronavirus est
quasiment malheureusement mais quasiment
un demi million de personnes on est con
qu'on commence à approcher des cinq cent
mille décès aux états unis qui font des
états unis le pays qui aura payé le plus
lourd tribut en termes de décès donc on
voit bien que la préoccupation des
années michael et autres elle et elle
est déjà je pense qu'on a déjà quasiment
d'une certaine manière un peu tourner la
page de donald trump en tout cas pour
ceux qui ont des préoccupations basiques
comme c'est le cas de chacun d'entre
nous aujourd'hui c'est vous parlez du
committee est évidemment est logiquement
la préoccupation numéro un il se trouve
tout de même qu'on soit fan ou non de
donald trump soutien ou non d'un an 30
avait annoncé le vaccin avant novembre
ce qui avait provoqué quelques
ricanements aux états unis mais ailleurs
également est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
américains louis font crédit quand même
d'avoir un vrai en tout cas mis les
milliards nécessaires pour que ce vaccin
soit prêt aussitôt j'ai le sentiment que
messi c'est pas simplement lié à
situation américaine ou simplement lié à
situation de oca donald trump nos
concitoyens et les personnes concernées
attendent surtout de retrouver un
semblant de vie normale à la fois pour
ceux dont on a parlé qui sont les pus
forte en étant soit malade trois décédés
mais aussi tous ceux qui n'ont pas
d'emploi aujourd'hui et vous savez que
il ya eu jusqu'à on a on a commencé à
réduire le chômage aux etats-unis mais
tout ça est un peu et particulièrement
d'un taux de chômage particulièrement
élevé pour toutes ces raisons je pense
que s'il doit y avoir un crédit accordé
à tel ou tel point
10dans que ce soit ne sortant que ce
soit le nouveau c'est lorsque dans sa
grande majorité la population américaine
on recommencera à vivre lorsque
l'amérique va réouvrir aujourd'hui les
écoles sont fermées
le pays est fermée dont vous voyez c'est
une situation qui à la fois sur le plan
économique sur le plan social est
extrêmement compliqué et c'est à ce
moment là on est vraiment sur une
situation où on attend des résultats que
tout plutôt que des annonces là pour le
coup les annonces ne suffisent pas merci
beaucoup pour votre analyse sur lot de
bons jours d'avoir été avec nous en tout
cas merci à vous